there's also another huge story breaking
in the last 24 hours from the New York
Times which says that Donald Trump's now
resigned personal attorney John Dowd
intimated discuss the possibility that
Donald Trump might pardon the indicted
Trump associates Michael Flynn and Paul
Manafort there are three people familiar
with these discussions that told the New
York Times that the discussions were
between Trump's now resigned / fired
lawyer John Dowd and the lawyers for
Michael Flynn and Paul Manafort and this
took place some time ago and what they
were discussing was if they were to
plead guilty but not to cooperate with
Muller would Trump be willing to pardon
them and the reason that Trump's lawyer
would be doing this is that trumps
interest would be that Flynn and Man
afford not give Moeller information that
might be used against Donald Trump maybe
say something that gets Trump in trouble
so the idea is a Flynn and Manafort
belief that Trump will pardon them they
all of a sudden have no reason to
cooperate with mola right the reason to
cooperate with Muller would be if they
don't believe they're going to get
pardoned and by cooperating they might
be able to get a lesser charge or lower
sentence if they are to be found guilty
at some point in the future if they know
or believe that Trump is just going to
pardon them they can just say to Muller
charge me prosecute me sentence me do
whatever the hell you want because they
know in the back of their minds that
Donald Trump is ultimately going to
pardon them and once again we get back
to the main question the main sort of
observation we've had all along with
Trump's behavior here if you did nothing
wrong do you have your lawyer start to
talk about pushing people not to
cooperate on the basis of a possible
pardon forthcoming if you did nothing
wrong do you worry about what Flynn and
Man afford are going to tell molar
because there would be nothing to tell
molar if you actually did nothing wrong
and this report is being denied by some
Trump associates but if you listen to
the denials listen to the language they
use they are saying things all in the
present
there is no consideration being given to
pardoning Flynn and mana fort there are
no discussions taking place at the White
House involving Donald Trump about
pardoning Flynn and Man afford that is
the present tense that is not a denial
of the fact that at the time that this
allegedly took place this is something
that was being discussed whether a Trump
knew about it or not that's sort of
another question I would presume that he
did so this is really not looking good
yet the behavior of innocent people it's
an unorthodox political or legal
strategy I would say yeah but I think it
could work
because if Trump just decides to pardon
everyone to part in Michael Flynn and
Paul Manafort and maybe even go further
and fire Robert Muller hmm it would be
big news for a couple of weeks but be
given the fact that Republicans have
controlled the House and Senate and
there are so many committed trumpets out
there in the country I think it would
blow over I don't know I mean there are
there are even Republicans who have said
if Moeller goes then that's where we go
to a new level it's the people like
Lindsey Graham and some others do they
really have the power to do that
unilaterally if the Republican Party at
large doesn't really want to do that I
don't know I this might be completely
naive of me but I would hope that if
that were to take place that there
actually would be repercussions but
you're generally pointing out something
that we've seen which is that the new
scandals just replace the previous ones
and we sort of forget and move on what
we do know is that last year Trump was
asking White House lawyers about how far
his ability to pardon goes we know that
in other meetings Donald Trump
specifically brought up the issue of
pardoning Michael Flynn and as usual all
of the roads lead us back to obstruction
of justice right is a promise or
implication of a possible pardon in
exchange for someone not cooperating
with investigators is that a form of
obstructing justice the answer is
actually legally unclear there are legal
experts that are divided on this issue
those who say that it would be
obstruction say listen the president has
pardoned powers but the president can't
use the pardon power to protect himself
that that would be a form of obstruction
the counter-argument is this is an
absolute power to
pardon that the president has the
motives of the pardon no matter whether
we can prove them or are just
speculating on them wouldn't be
prosecutable no matter what so
ultimately it's going to be a legal
battle that at this point we don't know
which which way it would go and then the
other angle is is this a form of witness
tampering
right and I I don't know the answer to
that it's tough to get a president on
that especially if Trump's lawyer is the
one having these conversations you'd
have to prove that Trump was somehow
involved in that directed or was
knowledgeable of it but the the window
of deniability here is closing the
desperation is clearly growing and by
the way related we also learned
yesterday that Paul Manafort seems to be
betting on a pardon from Trump at this
point there are legal sources that spoke
to CBS News and straight-up said man
afford strategy looks like is going to
be do not cooperate fight all the
charges through and up to and including
trial probably end up being found guilty
on something although we don't know yet
what and then count on a trump pardon
and that's where we are and as far as
Michael Flynn is concerned he's in a bit
of a different situation he seems to
have some motivations related to
protecting his son which might make him
comport himself differently than Paul
Manafort new definition of Magha I think
is making attorneys get attorneys that's
really what the motto is becoming here
of the Trump administration Michael
Cohen's got an attorney
Trump's attorneys now are seeking
counsel other attorneys in the
administration need to be represented
and we're very quickly headed towards a
constitutional crisis where the most
relevant question that will help us
resolve all of this might ultimately be
what are the limits of presidential
power period because when you look at
can the president be indicted when you
look at can the president use pardons to
protect himself when you look at all of
these questions what they all eventually
point to at their full conclusion if
this escalates is a decision that would
ultimately have to be adjudicated as to
what the limits are of presidential
power send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter
David Pakman show and we've got a good
one today I'm glad you're with us
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by war and
peace civil war if you've ever wanted to
go back in time and help the United
States defeat the Confederacy war and
peace Civil War is a mobile online
multiplayer strategy game that lets you
do exactly that you go back in time to
the Civil War you as a Union Army
commander lead your troops against the
Confederate States of America and it not
only tests your ability to strategize
but it also tests your historic
knowledge you can play online with
thousands of other players chat in real
time with other players and form
military alliances get advice and
strategies from real world historical
figures like Abe Lincoln and ulysses s
grant develop your bases research new
technology train huge legions of troops
even use brute force to destroy the
enemy warn peace Civil War has a
five-star rating in both the Google Play
Store and the iOS App Store thousands of
reviews check it out download it for
free right now on Android and iOS and of
course if you're watching this on
youtube use the link in the description
underneath this video